come on let's go
this guy moves take his head off do you
have any idea whose money
we got a 904 on Old Finch Road and we
got two dead
we got the money come on we killed two
people trying
two man in and out
what you thinking it's gonna be about
pills and money and pestle
I can understand what's at stake here
she's my niece I understand what's at
stake what do you know it's a damn
Empire body you're saying this outfit is
Mom
what are you dealing with locals that's
all nothing that can't be handled quick
I'll recover what was taken
morning Shelby
[Music]
hey look this can be worked out well
that's why I'm here
we're watching your family I got nothing
to do with this they do now
[Music]
hey Sheriff Shelby
believe I know you
okay
he won't tell me something
this ain't your world
you don't control this
I didn't ask for this
[Applause]
[Music]
and they always sliding towards the edge
it's up to you how comfortable you are
doing it
really